in this quick video i'm going to show
you how to sync your key fob back to
your nissan or infiniti car or suv right
now i just replace the batteries in my
key fob and the car will not unlock
but it will unlock
if i come up to the door and the car
will start so in order to do this i need
to sink the fob back to the car
using
this method you're going to hold and
unlock
the button and you're going to hold it
right up to the start button and you're
just gonna keep hitting the button until
you start hearing the doors click and
unlock now it's synced back to the car
now i can get out of the car
and now the car locks
it also unlocks and everything synced
back up please like this video and
subscribe to my channel thanks for
watching